we are deeply honored to accept this  award my father carl countryman started  countrymen associates over 50 years ago  he was as phenomenal a dad as he was an  audio engineer and inventor  i wish you were here with us tonight to  accept the award thanks to my incredible  mother carolyn who has been the common  thread throughout the company's history  and thanks to rosa pimentel who has been  our general manager and a member of our  family for more than 30 years  thanks to our exquisite cross people and  thanks to greg kovacs  who has been an amazing friend of  countrymen associates omar and i would  like to thank our families  aaron omer jr and isla melissa emma and  sophie  finally thanks to the academy and the  incredible motion picture community for  trusting us to let your talent shine  it is our profound privilege to be  associated with your remarkable work